wir beginnen disketten wir schlagen die
unendlichen weiten zurück was ist dass
ich weiß sie so ich lisa
wieso wie alle hier sind das erste was
klassen mit der enterprise macht ist er
haut sie kaputt das heißt sie erleidet
eine bruchlandung
die crew wird dann so in kleine teams
zerstückelt die sich alleine
durchschlagen
eine mannschaft wie kommen wir da wieder
raus besonders lustig wenn man mit
keulen spock als ein derartiges unit
behandelt die sich natürlich wahnsinnig
auf die nerven gehen bzw
doch weiß man nicht so genau wie nerven
hat aber jedenfalls triezen und quälen
sich gegenseitig sterbe ich nicht allein
im wesentlichen ist es dann planeten
abenteuer sehr interessantes planeten
abenteuer bei tatsächlich dieses sie
müssen sich selbst und einander retten
natürlich vieles offenbar an diesen
figuren woran man vielleicht noch gar
nicht gedacht hat ansonsten ist die
geschichte heftig militarisiert das
heißt man hat zu einer kriegsszenario
haut den ball was um die ohren dass viel
damit zu tun hat was heutzutage auf der
welt von amerika aus gesehen los ist und
was in amerika los ist von der welt
gesehen und ansonsten gibts auch noch
eine science fiction fabel die mit einem
geheimnisvollen gerät zu tun hat dass
ein bösewicht namens carl sich unter den
nagel reißen möchte aber warum sich da
im einzelnen handelt es eigentlich gar
nicht so wichtig das könnte auch eine
flasche riesling seien sie kennen wird
uns holen kann und genau das hat das
letzte sein was jansen hat das schöne
daran dass jetzt wirklich neues kapitel
aufgeschlagen wird ist dass man zwar
nicht mit der perfektion rechnen kann
die man bei uns inzwischen gewohnt ist
wenn er einen alten stoff anfasst in der
statik anfasst wenn das star wars
anfasst dass man aber mit überraschungen
rechnen kann ich sage nur soundtrack an
zwei stellen dass musik ist ein guter
song
und dass man etwas geschenkt bekommt und
dem man noch nicht so genau weiß was es
ist das heißt die bei den besten
geschenke neben verpackungen schütteln
frage stellen aufmachen überraschung was
zu spielen was zu machen ein paar
unsichere sachen und ein paar richtig
brilliante sachen und ganz toll ist
übrigens die neue figur bella
entschuldigung
das ist sein stuhl